hey youtubers it's Charlie so it's been
all but confirmed that bullseye and
Elektra are both going to join daredevil
season two in some capacity so this is
gonna be a quick breakdown of his
history in the comics there was this
rumor going around that Jason Statham
had been offered the part but in a
separate statement he kind of took a
verbal dump on the superhero genre so
he's not really an option just like they
did casting Charlie Cox's Matt Murdock I
think they're gonna go with a slightly
less well-known actor someone who's not
crazy expensive and will work really
well with the cast that they already
have that's a big problem across the
board for all kinds of TV shows and
movies you know they find great actors
but for some reason they just don't work
really well with the existing cast most
of you are probably familiar with the
Colin Farrell version of the character
from the Ben Affleck movie he is this
really you know weird psycho energy
about him a lot of people are you know
hoping that the he'll return to the role
I don't think that's gonna be the case
even though he is doing TV like he's one
of the main actors on true detective
season 2 the big takeaways you know like
just don't be surprised if the person
that ends up being bullseye is someone
you've never heard of before and that's
not a bad thing at all I'm kind of
expecting the same treatment for Elektra
I'm just finding an actress that's not
necessarily a huge a list star but
someone who works really well with
Charlie Cox and the rest of the cast how
many of you guys knew exactly who
Charlie Cox was when he was cast and
he's actually done a few big things but
this is all about bull's-eyes so here's
his comic book history so his real name
is supposedly Lester we haven't heard a
last name every time he showed up he's
always referred to as bullseye he
started out in 1976 in daredevil 131 in
a story called watch out for bullseye he
never misses
bullseye looking for publicity goads
daredevil into a public fight by killing
someone in broad daylight rewinding back
in time you know they changed his
backstory a couple times but let's start
with the original one first as a child
he grew up in the Bronx with a brother
in a really abusive father one of his
favorite things to do with his brother
was practice with rifles so eventually
he became an expert marksman all before
the age of 10 his brother ended up
setting fire to their apartment to try
and get rid of their crappy dad and
bullseye got placed in foster care
eventually his marksmanship skills made
him this amazing baseball pitcher which
ended up being a ticket to the majors
but
actually this is where things go sour so
he's pitching a game and kicking
everyone on the other team's asked like
those a complete no-hitter gets so bored
he asks his coach to take him out
coach refuses the batter for the other
team starts taunting him so he throws a
ball hits the batter in the head kills
him and that's kind of like the
beginning of his illustrious criminal
career they wreak on that during electro
solo title he gets captured by the US
government and tells them his origin
story but everyone kind of thinks that
he's lying in the newer origin story he
grew up in a trailer park still had an
abusive dad that he tried to kill and
make make it look like an accident but
it did it didn't work out
he was eventually recruited by the NSA
for his skills as an assassin trained a
rebel group in Nicaragua tried to take
over this cocaine business get get
involved with the mob but it all went
south when Punisher showed up he ended
up drawing a bull's-eye on his forehead
using his own blood just as a way to
taunt Punisher for not being able to hit
him with a bullet this is before he got
his bullseye costume so he crawls away
turns himself into DEA agents they tell
him to infiltrate the kingpins crime
organization he eventually goes rogue
and becomes this great assassin for hire
like I said though a lot of people feel
like that's false narration he actually
tried to get himself captured so that
they would take him to the prison where
his father was being held and he could
get revenge on him which he did the only
thing that's confirmed about his
backstory though is that he hates his
father like he had a really shitty
relationship with them that's what
happens whenever a criminal tells you
their backstory is you never know if
they're telling the truth so moving
along he became part of Thunderbolts
during Marvel's Civil War battled the
Skrulls during secret invasion then
became the new Hawkeye in Norman
Osborn's Dark Avengers during the Dark
Reign era whenever daredevil had taken
control the hand Osborn orders bullseye
had to take him down even though he
wasn't successful
he did end up killing a whole bunch of
people and making daredevil feel
responsible for it he enjoys taking
shots at heroes when he gets the chance
even if he can't kill them that's one of
the character traits I feel like Colin
Farrell nailed bullseye is completely
sadistic if you've been reading
daredevil lately like in the last couple
years you might also be familiar with
Lady bullseye who's a completely
different person I think the TV show is
gonna go with the original version of
bullseye the male version but Lady
bullseye helps make
original bullseye way more complex of a
character way more interesting her real
name is Maki Matsumoto as a child in
Japan she was taken in by the Yakuza
forced into sex slavery and eventually
was rescued or accidentally rescued by
the original bullseye he was in town on
a completely unrelated mission killed
all the people that were her captors on
his business
she was inadvertently freed and was so
inspired by what bullseye did that she
wanted to become a killer too she ended
up joining the hand got involved in this
plot using Matt Murdock's then wife
Milla Donovan ended up killing kingpins
girlfriend blaming Matt Murdock just as
a way to cause some chaos try to you
know try to get kingpin to start going
after daredevil again then used the
whole mess to take control of the hand
herself she also appeared in black
widows solo title on a mission to injure
Pepper Potts as opposed to the original
bullseye she really doesn't have any
notable powers she's more martial
arts-based
here's my big question for you guys do
you want to see a version of Lady
bullseye on the show or do you just want
them to keep it simple and go with the
original version just to clarify though
lady bullseye didn't replace bullseye or
anything like that they both recently
appeared she makes bull's eyes slightly
more sympathetic but he's still a pretty
rotten dude so it's not like she was a
gender bent version of bullseye
she's like the back girl to bull's-eyes
Batman but if you guys want to read some
cool bull's-eyes story lines read
daredevil 181 that's a story called
last hand where he goes after Elektra
then there's daredevil 196 to 199 it's a
storyline where he gets adamantium
stolen from Wolverine grafted onto his
body so he does have an adamantium
skeleton not not quite as good as
Wolverines but I probably I can do that
on the TV show because that's an x-men
thing then there's his big return from
the dead in volume 3 number 26 that's a
little bit more recent it also involves
Lady bullseye Thunderbolts also you know
really fun comic-book agreed to but
there's a whole lot more of it so it
just depends on how deep you want to go
logically what's probably gonna happen
is as kingpin stuck in jail is going to
hire bullseye to take down daredevil and
that's gonna be his entry to the story
if you guys haven't seen it I've already
done a daredevil season 2 video where I
explained the hand and some of the
storylines I think they're gonna explore
I'll add a link for it in the
description I've done
a couple daredevil season two videos
already but I'll probably do for my next
daredevil video is something just
entirely for the hand just because
they're pretty interesting organization
they show up quite a bit why you guys
wait for that you can click here for my
daredevil season 2 predictions you know
along with an explainer on Elektra ant
you can click here to learn about
guardians of the galaxy to James Gunn's
who's been dropping a bunch of details
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tomorrow
you